this is the first now major annual
sporting event to pull out of our city
and it's going to be a pretty big blow
orca mana looks at how it could impact
our city financially
this is a really big blow to las vegas
to have an event like the pbr finals
which is usually held here at t-mobile
arena leave our city is definitely not
something anyone wanted to hear
especially since vegas has been
rebranded in recent years as a sports
town in fact a new tourism campaign
boasts las vegas as the greatest arena
on earth a recent ad shows different
sports teams and venues around town and
it includes a couple seconds of bull
riding so the big question is what does
this mean for vegas's economy you'll
remember the national finals rodeo or
nfr was not held in las vegas last year
because of covet 19 restrictions our
economy took a major hit from that and
analyst jeremy aguero tells me we can
expect the same from not having the pbr
finals it's significant in terms of
the fact that a major event is leaving
our community generates millions of
dollars generates a lot of jobs wages
and salaries spending and things like
restaurants and at hotels all of that
this associated will be lost aguero
could not put a ballpark number on the
millions in expected losses but he adds
that while this will be a hit to las
vegas our economy has so many other
major sports events so we should not
worry too much and instead we should
focus on trying to get the pbr finals
back aguero also tells me that there's
still a high interest in las vegas from
professional sports teams and youth
leagues looking to make a move and he
also adds that pbr leaving doesn't
necessarily mean that we'll see the
exodus of other major events as well
reporting in las vegas orca mana 8 news
now
so for now we have one more round with
the pbr in las vegas the world finals
start on wednesday november 3rd and then
they'll wrap up sunday the 7th at
t-mobile